[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__]
[Music]
emaga is preparing to freak out which
that's an everyday occurrence really so
no news there no news there magazine
preparing to freak out it was balloons
then it was people dressed in devil
costumes uh tonight it will be at the
president United States gives the state
of the union and tells the truth when
they want to tell lies tomorrow it will
be about what he said and what he didn't
say and next Sunday we have the Super
Bowl
so I'm sure whatever debauchery
that the NFL allows at the halftime show
next Monday we'll be talking about their
freak out on that
hell
it's a it's a tough cycle to keep up
with their [__] and to keep up with
their free counts but we do that here at
the Tony Michaels podcast
because we have to show you what they're
saying and how they're melting the minds
of real America that's [__] trending
this morning again
on Twitter from a Maga Republican real
America they wouldn't know [__] real
America if it sat right directly on
their face they [__] wouldn't know
they just wouldn't know they're more
concerned about what genitalia M Ms have
and people dancing around the devil
costumes
it's really stupid stuff I don't know
what to tell you this is what I got to
work with
I mean I just come here to talk about
what the hell's going on
and what the hell's going on is some
crazy ass [__] crazy [__] out there
but you know that's what happens
win a very loud very loud part of our
country
has a large group of people it's a small
percentage I keep telling you that this
idea that America is divided up half and
half
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense
that is not true and and the majority of
America does not believe that garbage
go ask your friends go ask them even the
[__] boxes right even the [__] boxes
just start asking them about issues
don't ask them about who they vote for
what they feel about this president or
the last president just ask them
ask him
is your salary enough hell no
do you feel like you're getting [__]
by your job hell yes
do you feel like if there's a chance
that you'd have a medical bill that
maybe you'd go broke
and your [__] bank account would be
drained hell yes
this is what we have to do this is the
language that we have to use
it is imperative it is important
that we that we do that
I hope tonight that Joe Biden and I'm
I'm sure that he will use some of that
language in the State of the Union
Address now the funny part is
that the state of the union is something
that every
president does all of them they all do
it every year it's it's a it's kind of a
thing
I don't know maybe the Maga
America First Nazis haven't caught on to
this
but it's a thing that happens every year
and every single one of them do it even
their orange Mussolini Jesus did it
foreign
and no one was really freaking out ahead
of time about what he was gonna say
because he is predictably unpredictable
now I think Joe Biden is very
predictable as well I don't know if
you've been paying attention to what's
been happening in this country the last
two years Joe Biden is very predictable
very predictable
what do I mean by that Joe Biden's
interest is in the American people real
America
as these [__] these [__]
moglodytes put it
what they mean by real America let me
let me give you a sense of what they
mean by real America white people that
that's what they mean they mean white
Maga supporters is what they mean oh
yeah and they're few token people of
color manga supporters too those who who
who who
kowtow to white supremacy that's who
they're talking that's what they're
talking about they're talking about
white privilege white supremacy and
White America when they say real America
I'm gonna show you a video and I I
wanted to show it yesterday but it's
very appropriate today to show it uh in
the lead up
to all the freak out that we're gonna
have because I know I know I know
because it's gonna be Sarah Huckabee
Sanders that's gonna give the rebuttal
and the response to Joe Budden you know
you know where Republican politicians
careers go to die do you know where they
go to die they go to die in the response
to a democratic presidents State of the
Union speech that's where they go to die
I don't know if you remember this there
was a guy named Marco Rubio who wanted
to be president of the United States he
thought he's going to be president oh
this guy this guy thought he's going to
be president of the United States have
you heard from Marco lately maybe we
should check in on Marco I haven't heard
from him haven't seen him I haven't been
reading Bible verses from him
surprisingly on Twitter he's probably
typing them in over there it's just Elon
is stuffing my [__] timeline full of
a bunch of other Nazis not Marco who's a
sympathizer right but we should check on
Marco but Marco oh he was going to be
president he was the new face of the
Republican party this is going to be
fantastic of course he's a worthless
piece of [__] he can't do anything he's
the laziest [__] in Washington
D.C probably one of the laziest in the
entire country I mean George Santos does
more from his car to his office
then Marco Rubio has done in 12 years
it's it's the God's honest truth and
George Santos is a lying sack of [__]
he's a Republican and fits really well
with him
but Margo Rubio was going to be the new
Star remember and then he just he just
couldn't keep hydrated he just couldn't
do it he failed at hydration
that's how [__] worthless he is
his political aspirations dead Dead on
Arrival Sarah Huckabee Sanders now this
this is a vile piece of [__] who really
does believe that she's gonna be
president like she thinks she's gonna be
president
I mean she lied for one for years why
not be one right
and her daddy
her daddy wanted to be one so [__]
bad he ran I don't know 22 times or some
[__] for president United States
now now we just he just hangs out with
Ted Nugent and they they sing racist
[__] on some Trader TV News Network
but Sarah Huckabee Sanders wants to be
wants to be
the dictator of the Free World isn't
that funny how that works these people
really have a [__] skewed View
of what Freedom Liberty in America is
don't they when they call real America
because again they're saying White
America
is what they're saying when they say
real America
he even has that it even has that nice
KKK undertone to it don't you think
like America First like you know America
first didn't work out so well for him
I have I mean I bring them as America
First Nazis because they thought oh yeah
that phrase is really gonna it's really
gonna get people the majority of
Americans behind it America first
and then they kind of found out that
was a Ku Klux Klan thing it was a it was
a uh America First Nazi thing during the
second world war when sympathizers of
Adolf Hitler were trying to gain support
here in America so that way America
didn't go there and beat his ass
but you know history and [__] it just
it's all kinds of weird stuff to them
they get weird feelings you start you
know bringing up the words critical and
theory and race and Nazis and it really
gets them in the fields right they can't
handle it they're [__] snowflakes
they get really offended when you tell
the truth
same way as real America they're they're
saying it out loud it's it's just
another version right
of America first
same [__] is make America great again
and what they're saying
they don't want their white privilege
taken away and a matter of fact they
want to expand their white privilege
they want to expand their Christian
privilege they want to be have the
freedom to tell you
what you can and cannot [__] do what
you can and cannot believe who you can
cannot [__] who you can cannot love what
books you can and cannot read
what songs you can dance to in a devil
costume I'm dead serious this is [__]
they want
listen this [__] idea
this idea
that there is one major party in this
country who would who would gather up
in a room and decide that it is just
unfathomable that someone would get in a
devil costume and dance to a song called
Unholy on a television station that can
be turned off
and they would ban that they would ban
it they would make sure that someone
couldn't do it
more so they would make sure someone
couldn't do it at all not just on
television at all that's what they want
and the reason why is because they don't
give a [__] about Real Americans they
give a [__] about how they want to shape
the white Christian nationalism in
America that's what they want it's white
supremacy folks this real America [__]
that's what it is
real and raw
they're just hiding it again
right
and make America great again Merrick
first now we're to real America
once we expose them and we keep mocking
real America
they'll move to another phrase
but we must
we must lean in to our democracy we must
lean in to equity and equality
and using like I do and I try to do it
I'm not always perfect don't get me
wrong I I make a lot of mistakes
humans are apt to do that
but lean in white people hey white
people out there if you're listening
lean into your white privilege and use
it to destroy that very thing
use it
it may be a powerful tool
to destroy white privilege
and in this nonsense once and for all in
this country
now fascism is on the rise around the
world
so they want you to believe
so they want us to believe that
Christian nationalism is on the rise
here
again I think it's a very small
percentage
they're just very [__] loud
and there's a large number of them to be
very loud
what we must do in our democracy
is engage and do the very things that
democracies do
which is be louder
have a louder voice
yell and scream at the top of our lungs
and I think it's imperative
and I think we must form coalitions
around the strength of liberalism not
not that liberalism is weak
we must coalesce around the idea that
liberalism and democracy is strength
it's what we have to do
and we should welcome anyone
to our Coalition who is willing to be in
that fight rather it be former
Republicans
rather it be rather it be never trumpers
rather it be moderates independents
social social Democrats Democratic
Socialist socialist
whoever it may be in that fight against
authoritarianism we must fight
we have to
that's why in recent days I've spoken
out
against tyt everyone keeps getting
[__] crazy about me speaking out
against The Young Turks
do you want to know my main beef
with The Young Turks
and their commentary that generally
comes from their Network and a lot of
people said oh Tony but Young Turks says
good things about minus touch and you're
you're a partner with my such yes so
what
so what
oh well young jerks you know what they
do they speak out against Democrats when
they when they're corrupt yeah and I'm
speaking out against them
as someone who wants a coalition who
wants them to do better
for a democracy I'm speaking out against
them so take this as me speaking out
against the left you boneheads
listen when you tell people well there's
no sense of voting no sense of voting
because Democrats aren't going to do
anything for you anyways you God damn
right I'm gonna speak out against that
when they're encouraging people not to
vote because oh well there's only both
sides are the same both sides are the
same and Democrats aren't going to do
[__] either because I've already started
to hear this [__] this morning
about how Joe Biden's accomplishments
that he's going to talk about didn't go
far enough
that's that's that's what that is the
narrative I guarantee you now I'm not
gonna go turn it on today
but I guarantee you if you go over and
you listen to tyt the next 72 hours that
is what's going to be said folks and you
tyt lovers out there that come watch me
good go watch them and tell me I'm
[__] wrong I don't even have to watch
I'm gonna have to watch to know what
they're gonna say I know what they're
going to say I know I know the direction
of their commentary
and if you want if you want to win this
battle of democracy
then we have to challenge them too
we have to challenge the Nina Turners
yeah I said it a lot of people love Nina
Turner hey I agree with Nina Turner on a
lot of things I just don't agree with
her authoritarianism I don't
I don't and I won't I never will believe
in authoritarian I don't give a [__] who
it is I don't give a [__] who they want
to be king and by who I mean anyone in
this country if you want a king if you
want a dictator I'm not on your I'm not
on your [__] side
so if you want democracy
if you want to do the hard work of
liberalism then let's do it let's do it
then we are D then we are like-minded
and we are like-minded enough to be in a
coalition no matter what we disagree on
or agree on
but but I'm telling you I'm telling you
Maga and fascism is a huge threat in
this country to our democracy they want
to smash it with a hammer and the answer
is not to smash democracy with a hammer
so that they don't smash it with a
hammer the answer is democracy
and it's a long hard [__] road it's
not easy
it's not easy
I mean look at the small tiny steps
we've taken in the last 50 years we
should be taking long strides by this
measure
but we're not taking long strides we're
not
we're not
and the biggest reason why is because of
fascism and trumpism in this country
but there's an underlying other reason
why
is because us as a coalition have to
stay together in the idea
that liberal democracy can and will
shake out
regardless of where the minimum wage
Falls or if you call it Universal Health
Care or if you just call it don't go
broke because of a medical bill
listen to me when I tell you this
almost every single measure
of policy and structure of our society
in this country the pro-democracy
Coalition probably agrees on over 90
percent
90 percent
so we're going to let that 10 percent
that we disagree on destroy our
democracy and let fascists destroy our
democracy because I'm telling you over
the next 72 hours over the next 72 hours
the messaging in the narrative is going
to be crucially important
and if the media which they most
certainly will not do the correct job
because they're so scared of being
called Liberal oh my God they're biased
biased to what the truth the [__] out of
here with that nonsense quit your
bitching about reporting the truth and
it seems like you're on the liberal side
well of course you're on the [__]
liberal side when you report the truth
the goddamn America first real American
Nazi party
I'm gonna have to start calling them
that we're gonna have to Brand them that
way
they're not for the truth at all
how many [__] lies they're gonna
they're going to pile
on Americans over the next 72 hours
after Joe Biden gives his speech
just lie after lie after lie after lie
mountains and mountains and mountains of
lies that we will have to combat
it's gonna take a lot of work
a lot of work
because most people in this country
we've talked about this before most
people in this country do not pay
attention to politics
most people in this country do not
understand the process of our Civics
which is a shame
we should be teaching people in in
schools
as much about Civics as we teach about
math
the moment they begin to read they
should be learning about civics
and just you know pure decency
but that's a whole other subject
but those there's folks in this country
that are way more worried way more
worried
about what Kelsey brother is going to
walk home
with the Super Bowl trophy
this weekend
we're way more concerned about what
snacks they're gonna have
for their Super Bowl party what they're
gonna have to prepare
to go to the Super Bowl party that
they're going to attend
they're way more focused
on if they're going to take off work
Monday because they're going to be hung
over from the Super Bowl party
than they are about tonight
and 9 P.M
eastern time when the president United
States comes out after his first two
years in office
and lays the groundwork
for the next two years
and his inevitable run
in 2024 which he will be the nominee
again let me tell you another reason why
I'm going to keep speaking out against
The Young Turks tyt David Pacman and the
like
is because they're going to say [__]
like this well is there another Democrat
that is better suited do Democrats want
another it doesn't [__] matter
it doesn't matter if there's another
better suited Democrat it doesn't matter
if the American people want another
Democrat there's only one person that is
going to win the Democratic primary
folks
these are facts that I'm giving you
you can bet on it you do not you do not
have to pay a lot of attention you don't
even have to ask those stupid [__]
questions because I'm giving you the
answer right now the Democratic nominee
for president in 2024 will be President
Joe Biden his running mate will be
Kamala Harris you can [__] Bet On It
he will not have any viable challenge in
any Primary in any state mark my words
who in the [__] would run against this
record
who
oh well Gavin Gavin Newsom
the same reason why Ron DeSantis is not
going to get in the race as long as
Grandpa Poopypants is alive is the same
reason why Gavin Newsom is not going to
get in the race with Joe Biden he will
get destroyed
Gavin Newsom knows this Gavin newsom's
not a dumb [__]
and Gavin Newsom has plenty of time in
2028 to run a campaign against Ron
DeSantis in a general election he knows
this
Gavin Newsom is not a dummy
and by suggesting at all well is there
another candidate oh look at this poll
hey hey Tony look at this pull this poll
says a bunch of [__] about how the
American people want someone other than
Joe bite we always want someone
different
The Grass Is Always Greener folks it
doesn't matter who it is
but there's only one fact remains of how
our democracy Works how our Civics Works
how the political parties work how the
primary elections work
mark my words down February 7th 12 25
PM eastern time Tony Michael said on
Tuesday
Joe Biden will be the Democratic nominee
there's no reason for discussion and you
can go listen to all the polls and you
can pull up all the evidence you want
about why this [__] wants this
and why this [__] wants that
as long as Joe Biden wants to be
president he's going to be the nominee
that's just how it's gonna work
the same way that Donald Trump is the
leader of their party he didn't slink
away he didn't go away
he's gonna be their nominee
Donald Trump and Joe Biden are gonna
have a rematch
as long as Grandpa poopy pants doesn't
choke on a cheeseburger and let me tell
you Rhonda Santos oh he's a snake in the
grass he's waiting oh man he's way he's
watching every bucket of chicken that
[__] eats he's like oh yeah get
down to that dark meat buddy get that
[__] chicken fat he's begging he's
begging for KFC
to give him the extra crispy choke on
that chicken leg I'm telling you
this is how it's going to be
and until something changes until
something changes drastically changes
these are the facts that you need to
work with
you do not have to you do not have to
operate in [__] La La Land
that the media wants to create
that tyt wants that's right you tyt
lovers t-y-t creates a fantasy land it's
fantasy it's [__] fantasy it's not
real
the idea that there's another Democrat
that can mount a challenge against Joe
Biden is ridiculous
and I guarantee you tonight that Joe
Biden is going to prove that
and he is going to stake a claim to that
nomination tonight
by laying out to the American people in
a certain type of language
of what he did
and what the Congress did prior
to the America first real American Nazis
taking over
the House of Representatives
and hell-bent on destroying our
government and our economy
by absolutely refusing to raise the debt
ceiling on debt they passed that they
voted on
absolutely going to refuse to keep the
government open when it comes to it in
September because they won't have a
budget they don't have a budget [__]
they didn't have a budget Kevin McCarthy
probably didn't even have anything
scratched out on a [__] napkin when
he went and talked to the president of
the United States
he has no clue because the Republicans
plan the America first real American
Nazis plan is no plan they have no plan
that is the plan
so we have to get our narrative we have
to get the trajectory of our messaging
correct
it is crucial over the next two years
rather you like Joe Biden Kamala Harris
or you don't like them
you're gonna [__] hate the
alternative everyone stick around it's
Tuesday we at Texas Paul of course we do
on Tuesdays I want to stick around don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
making and eating hardens for January
6th you see that Marjorie Taylor green
and the gamble what the [__] you gotta
be kidding me apparently there's
breaking news as well we're following
everything Kevin McCarthy is confirmed
that George Santos
is facing a house house epic
investigation whatever that means in the
new Republican ethics yeah okay
Republicans and ethics yeah
Republicans being in charge of an Ethics
Committee are you [__] kidding me
oh my God they're getting worked their
way out of a wet paper sack let alone
get rid of a vote
and Kevin McCarthy is gonna have a tough
time getting rid of George Santos so
maybe we'll have some more on that
um also someone's pointing out in the uh
in the chat uh Sarah Huckabee Sanders
I resemble that remark I'm a heck too
someone called me um because of my tyt
comments or something they said oh Tony
you're gonna be a right winger soon you
have this uh what what the hell was it
um
what the hell was it Bumpkin oh yeah
Bumpkin I mean call it Country Bumpkin
they I think they thought that offended
me
I am a country pumpkin Demi I am a
country buff man like that's the whole
point
and and the idea that somehow I'm gonna
slink to the right because I'm a white
dude and I yell and scream you are you
are [__] out of your mind you were
out of your mind if you think I'm gonna
walk away from democracy and want
autocracy you realize you realize that
they do all that for ratings and money
right and it's all fake just like Tucker
Carlson doing his fake little propaganda
on Fox News
that's all fake and I'm going to show
you a clip today and we're gonna get
Texas Paul's takes on this but I think
it's stochastic terrorism if you want to
know my opinion and I think the only
reason why Tucker Carlson is stoking
just can't just stochastic terrorism is
because it's good for his pocketbook
because he knows the re the listeners
that are watching
are gonna get all stoked up woo yeah
let's do that and really get him to
watch
trust me I know this
this is why I'm not going to slink to
the right wing because here's something
I fundamentally believe about voices and
commentary and radio I told this story a
lot on this show but I'm gonna tell it
again
I used to listen to three hours almost
every single day to Rush Limbaugh I
beamly disagree with everything that bio
piece of [__] said
I mean I would be in the car yelling can
you imagine me yelling yelling at the
[__] radio almost every single moment
every single moment he was speaking
but the reason why I listened to Rush
Limbaugh is because I didn't have to
listen to anyone else
to know exactly what the right wing was
going to say
exactly what the right-wing narrative
was going to be what their messaging was
what the talking points were
the reason why is because rushland ball
was on noon Eastern
he was the very first one to start
diving into the news before the news
cycle closed
and the Evening News came on for these
bumpkins that you called me
for these white country bumpkins to
watch the local news
and the Evening News you know they have
30-minute ABC and CBS has the 30-minute
Nightly News [__]
because Rush Limbaugh his goal
was to tell them why they were gonna be
mad
about the news that night
so follow me on this here's the timeline
these country bumpkins get up in the
morning
they eat their breakfast they go to work
they got the radio on there's a bunch of
them sitting around in an office and
they're all like yeah we hate we hate
everybody but white people I'm just and
they don't say that out loud I mean but
that's kind of the attitude right and
they turn on rushland Ball and Rush
Limbaugh tells them everything they're
supposed to be pissed off about
before they see it on the Nightly News
and before they get in the grocery store
line and buy a newspaper this [__] used
to happen
the [__] used to happen you'd go to the
grocery store get your eggs your milk
and then you get a newspaper before you
leave at the register they'd have them
in stacks on the registers
and rustling ball would tell you
he would give you why you're supposed to
be [__] pissed off about what the
media is saying and how what the media
is saying is against you
and it's not for white men
it's it's against white men it was the
alpha male talk before the alpha male
talk on the inner lips it really was
really truly was
and he shaped
an entire generation
across Generations but an entire voting
block of people who were primed
to defend their white privilege with
white supremacy
to defend
white supremacy with fascism
to defend white supremacy with
authoritarianism he primed them
waiting for just that one buffoon
who would let the Tail Wag the Dog and
boy did he ever meet his match with
Trump
Rush Limbaugh could never have dreamed
of a better person letting the Tail Wag
the Dog than Donald Trump
because he played to their every whim he
played to their every delusional
grievance
every [__] one of them that Rush
Limbaugh would scream every single day
and it was very effective it has been
proven to be very effective
and there's one thing that Rush Limbaugh
understood
better than almost anyone out there
as vile
as that [__] piece of [__] is and I I
would love to dance on his grave every
single day
for what he did to our [__] democracy
in our country and more than anything
the people who he mind [__]
and deluded
but it's not about what he said first
it's about how he said it first
he caught your attention
he got you to pay attention he got those
bumpkins
to listen to his [__]
and convince them of the opposite of
their interest
that's what he did and that is the
residual result of what we're dealing
with right now in Maga in America First
and real American Nazis
this is what we're dealing with
and it is imperative it is imperative
that us as pro-democracy
Coalition the Liberals small l
the Liberals out there who believe in
equality and equity
and do not want authoritarianism we do
not want a dictator
and we definitely don't want a religion
telling us what we can and cannot do
we must
we must do the same exact thing in
response
and I know oh you can't fight fire with
fire
this isn't fire folks
these are these are missiles
these are nuclear bombs in our democracy
this is not little stuff
they want to fracture our constitution
they want to tear it up and wipe their
asses with it so much so that their
leader the person who is going to be the
nominee of the America first real
American Nazi party
said I want to terminate the
Constitution to Crown me king and
they're like yeah we're here
that's great
because they know he's not for equity
they know he's not for equality
they know
what white Christian nationalists have
all the power and all to say in the
country as long as he
gets to be king
I know Texas Paul thinks I'm right he
grew up in rural White America I know I
and I don't know if he self-identifies
as a blumpkin I mean I'm a I'm a bumpkin
Texas fall are you are you a are you a
bumpkin is it uh is that fair to say oh
yeah I'm hillbilly as it gets man I am
somebody in the in the in the chat asked
what what do you what did you use
castoria for I knew the answer I mean I
miss him Billy As It Gets
well I mean this is you know and
um the reason why
it wasn't rigged you're just a loser the
reason why I keep um pounding away
because people are mad that I'd say
Steph about tyt and I I and David Pacman
and the like again I just want them to
get their asses in gear here
is all I want Texas well I think tyt and
Pac-Man
um Can can do the job I don't think they
can't do the job I think they're
refusing to do the job this idea that in
20 because you watched it in 2022 and
again you're gonna see it over the next
72 hours if you go over there and watch
that garbage if you watch that trash
that's trying to dilute your mind into
believing that both sides are the same
and Democrats are the same as
Republicans don't vote for Democrats oh
my God Democrats sent me another
fundraising email
listen folks it takes [__] money to
get elected it takes money to form a
government in this country right now and
if you want to get rid of that idea you
want to reform campaign Finance put
Republicans in charge make sure to make
way for republicans and see how campaign
Finance gets changed this is all
ridiculous Texas Paul that somehow
somehow I'm the [__] and I'm the one
who's being anti-democratic and I'm the
one who is attack attacking the left
when I say hey keep keep the noise down
about self-suppressing your vote
yeah that's why I created the ride or
die Democrats I mean we fight like hell
in the primaries we you know we're a big
tent party we have a lot of different
people with a lot of different views and
we Slug It Out man you fight for what
you believe in but once those primaries
are over you walk in that [__] booth
and you pull the blue blue handle it's
that simple it's that freaking simple
and let me tell you something all that
[__] you were talking about Joe Biden
about you know he's going to be the
nominee no [__] he's going to be the
nominee Joe Biden is on track to being
the greatest president we have ever had
he is on track to being the greatest
president we have ever had you think
about great presidents and what they
accomplished look at their
accomplishment and then compare it to
what Joe Biden's done in two [__]
years well you know you know that you
know the similarities between the
presidents that you would think of
um that have are great presidents when
you look at their record the reason why
we consider them great presence in
American history
is one reason what they did for the
American people not the tax cuts they
gave to the rich they you know not the
wars they won or the wars they fought
that is not what makes a great president
in in in history and we will look back
on Joe Biden I'm sure in 20 30 years and
we will have a totally different
perspective because he will be put in
the perspective of History
um and and he'll probably be held on a
higher pedestal than we do right now but
this again the tyts the David packman's
of the world they're like oh yeah he
accomplished a lot Texas Paul oh yeah he
may have got the the pack act he may
have got you know the inflation
reduction act the coveted Relief act he
may have got infrastructure but you know
what text Paul it didn't go far enough
it didn't go it's not it doesn't suit
how far I wanted it to go and listen
anyone who's pro-democracy
that is an argument for another day
you must celebrate democracy in the
moment that you have
and you must fight for more democracy
and more progress down the road
but to but to say I'm not going to
support a party because they made
progress but not enough
they didn't make enough progress and
really honestly some of his progress
isn't exactly
his fault I mean you look at the student
loan debt relief the only reason why
that plan hasn't been fully implemented
is because of the America First Regal
America Nazis that's the reason why so
it's not always the the quintessential
thing to attack Democrats because will
there's Tony there's corruption I get
this I ain't this coming well they call
out corruption on on this other side
they call out Democrats Texas Paul I'm
like I'm calling them out are you
listening I me on the left I'm a liberal
and calling them out uh Gabe Sanchez
knows what I'm talking about maybe maybe
hey you're in your new setting again
do you like his new background Texas
Paul I still have to put the stuff up
it's really I know that I gotta put the
honors
you should put your group and then do
your old background on the green screen
until you get everything up and then oh
I could do that yeah yeah but I would I
don't know if I have it just by itself
no so would I have to reset up the old
one yeah oh so yeah and then move
everything around to the other side
Texas ball you listen to this guy you
listen to this yeah you had to change
around his feng shui you explained it
yesterday he even gave us the definition
what feng shui uh is your background is
pretty much all all the same all the
time I have mine's going away here my
wife's just just every day every show Mr
Texas Paul is riding my ass about the
gun the gun cabinet's gotta go and we
gotta get some pictures up there mate so
folks all right we're gonna do it your
background's gonna do all this oh yeah
we're gonna tear all this [__] out and
put some pretty pictures up maybe a big
flag back there I don't know I must be a
trendsetter because I changed I changed
my room around I don't know three or
four months ago or something like that I
don't remember I must be a trendsetter
Gabe's one to change his room Texas
balls I mean it's not so much you were
saying
hey did you guys hear the breaking news
apparently um Kevin McCarthy has
announced uh ahead of the State of the
Union I think it's actually planned here
to suck up the news cycle but apparently
there is a ethics investigation house
and ethics investigation if there is any
left under the Republicans into George
Santos
um which I wouldn't say that
no there isn't they can say there is but
there is well
they gutted the Ethics Committee so how
do you have how does the Ethics
Committee actually have a legitimate
investigation right it's especially
[__] it's exactly what you're saying
it's to suck up a news cycle right
and when they when they gutted it he
goes fantastic like no joke that's what
he said he said it was fantastic
direct quote yeah that is a that is
someone who has nothing to hide never
says oh it's fantastic that the ethics
group was gutted that would look into
the alleged crimes
uh I just found out I just read this
morning on on New York Times that uh
that one of so as people know I'm this
George Santos uh pet scam is is deep I'm
[__] in the [__] right now horrible
I'm drudging through got your waders on
do you know what waiters are the high
boots yeah yeah yeah so I've got those I
mean look I'm getting it's getting
pretty close like where where the where
the top of the boots are here uh the
[__] I'm going through and trying to
track these people down people that are
no longer affiliated with him or not I
have multiple accounts online I'm trying
to dig through one of the leads and they
didn't go into a lot of detail but they
did get a hold of this one woman I was
trying to get in touch with Andrea dos
Santos who ran a phone whoa whoa whoa
whoa what yeah the reason the reason is
there's a huge the other thing that
people don't realize is there is a huge
Brazilian population that he worked with
specifically and I don't know the reason
but there is a huge Brazilian population
that works specifically with animal
rescue stuff I don't know why I can't I
can't assume why it's happening so you
found no evidence of why that is a thing
I don't know I don't know why that's a
thing but that is the thing for whatever
reason but everyone it just maybe it
just may be coincidence right you know
different different people who are
Brazilian own these animal rescues I
found one that he worked with that is no
longer active status but they still
are active online it's weird
but one of the leads that I had was this
farm that he had a GoFundMe for and I
have all of the the screenshots for it
and stuff but um
I was trying to get in touch with woman
and I reached out to her she never got
back to me and then I find out today
that it was a story on New York Times is
this [__] Farm I was looking into
because basically how it happened was
they said they were going to open up
this farm and Friends of pets United was
going to fundraise for this Farm to help
it's like a dog Refuge yeah it was like
it was an animal rescue so it was an
actual farm so it could be any kind of
animals not just yeah it was it was farm
animals and then they were renovating a
barn to have as like a dog mainly kind
of kennel okay
did this fundraiser there's another
person I need to contact uh who looks
like he's on roid's to the max
um but they ran this fundraiser and I
had the Assumption I was like I'm I this
this this this Farm is like inactive
especially around dog rescues I don't
know what happened around 2018 that kind
of just
went silent and then I'm reading this
article and it turns out that this
person
uh This Woman Andrew dosanto said that
she contacted contacted contacted trying
to get in touch with him and says that
she owes him I don't know he owes him or
he owes her I'm sorry he owes her okay
um two thousand
like just shy of three thousand dollars
I think three thousand dollar that
amount is like a pattern with
um with Santos and it's really weird
that there's a Dos Santos because we've
been saying Ron DeSantis George but here
here's Victor's um take on the breaking
news which uh Victor I like you but I
think you're oh boy you're getting way
too excited way too quickly I agree with
Texas Paul here it's it's not really an
investigation just an announcement of
one Kevin McCarthy uh Victor says
breaking Kevin McCarthy just said that
George Santos is currently facing a
house ethics investigation
um this is long overdue and I hope by
the end of the investigation every
Republican will call for George Santos
to resign no they won't they're not
going to he's already buddy buddied with
uh Marjorie Taylor green and Mac ants
are likely to protect him here
um he is undeserving to be a member of
Congress which that I'd agree with that
that is true but I don't think it's uh
like Texas Paul said I don't think it's
actually that much of an Ethics
investigation because there's not an
Ethics Committee to investigate really
and they don't have the power and the
rules to do that they stripped it away
uh the other thing too
um is again there's I think Kevin
McCarthy's trying to step on the news
cycle here but there's also a story out
there Texas Paul do you know about this
um apparently there was sexual
harassment or something of the sort some
some um some sort of physical assault
that was or I'm not exactly sure when
George Santos towards the staffer some
people were asking me the other day if
it was the the young staffer that used
to be with Madison Gotham that was with
him in the elevator in some of the
original Santos runs I don't know if you
know what I'm talking about the run from
outside to inside his office chasing him
they haven't really told us who it was
uh but we know that it was somebody at
first they said it was somebody that was
actually had been hired on to be a
staffer but wasn't hired yet and it was
kind of like uh so like in an interview
gist of it yeah the gist of it was it
was like a casting couch situation you
know if you want the job you gotta you
know but then they're saying you know
then like you say there's some news
reports that have come out and and guys
I'll be honest with you I am not Gabe
I'm a commentator Gabe has a talent for
digging into things he goes in and he
actually does the work of a journalist I
rely on the work of journalists and I
will tell you right now this is
something that has not been dug into
very deeply because the corporate media
just has no desire to they really don't
they you know this
the Republicans are in such bad shape
doing such a shitty job that going all
in on George Santos could put a nail in
their coffin so I have to tell you the
corporate media is not going to dig into
this so I don't have a lot of
information on this because I haven't
been making phone calls and whatnot
Gabe would probably be a better Source
on this here's uh and I'll send this to
you Tony yeah yeah yeah cause I'm trying
to look for it this is one one of the I
don't yeah so this came out was today
the seventh this came out yesterday it
looks like and this goes against uh the
link I sent you is for a GoFundMe now
this is like again this is me digging
around and finding this one this is the
event
that the New York Times is referencing
but the New York Times doesn't bring
this to friends of pets United is that
right so this is what it is this is a uh
went back through uh if you scroll down
so this is like a screenshot because
this is on a web archive right yeah yeah
so they so luckily some of the stuff is
no longer available because GoFundMe
shut it all down right there's some
actual GoFundMe this is the actual image
I mean the image of it I should say well
I mean you can still interact with it if
you wanted to but it is a it is a
snapshot in time of when this went on so
basically see okay ready scroll down
real quick
George Anthony devalder Santos okay that
is one that is one Alias that he made on
on so he was using both names
I have record of him going by George
Anthony devolder Santos I have him going
by Anthony D Santos I have him going by
George Anthony devolder Santos is his
legal name George Anthony devolder
Santos well he goes by uh I I I and
again I don't know the answer to this
question because no one's asking it like
no one can ask it George Sanchez don't
why are you doing these students because
honestly if if his name real if his
legal name really is because it's not
out of the realm of possibility that his
name could be George Anthony devolder
Santos that really is his name why
wouldn't he just [__] say that like I
go by bolt because it is my name right I
don't know I'm not sure but I can tell
you this the the fact that
he has one two three four possibly five
I have to go back through because some
of these accounts have been George
devolder was another GoFundMe that has
been shut down Anthony devolder is
another one that I can still find active
where he fundraised for the memorial of
his mother who died on multiple
occasions
um Anthony D Santos is another one I
even have a post from George Santos
where he makes a passive aggressive
comment
where he says oh he says uh oh great
only one person donated
and it was for this
um it's in Portuguese but basically it's
fundraising money you know donate five
ten twenty dollars for this this uh I
think it was a natural disaster that
happened in Brazil
this little village
um but then he changed the he changed
the thumbnail from the like
uh the village flag symbol and then he
put it he put a dog's face on there so
that's a weird kind of thing that I'm
it's weird but anyway only ten dollars
was raised for this other non-pet
related GoFundMe and I don't know if
this is where he started to think about
this but that was created back in
November 6 2015. so I've got multiple
accounts of him some active some
inactive but he's got four or five
different aliases that he's gone by
whether he was trying to double here is
here is uh actually one here right and
Andrea now this is an update I don't
know if this is the most recent this is
a scr this is a screen right so this is
the this is the most this would be the
most current version of what we've seen
so there's no other version this is from
2017 September
um it actually says the name please
contact Andrea dos Santos is that the
same Andrea dos Santos that you were
speaking so that's the one that's the
one uh
um that is in that is that is referenced
in this New York Times article but again
no they haven't you know no one's really
sharing these screenshots I don't know
if they have this one they might have
found her through another connection
that I don't want to reveal on the show
right now
um but again all of these people I don't
know why but a lot of these people
within this dog rescue community and it
also is one where it's just a bunch of
people sharing photos online of these
animals
in their house in their living room in
their in their kitchen whatever because
they've rescued them it's just a bunch
of like
social posts that are done not ones that
are done officially through a rescue so
it's a little weird I don't know why I
haven't been able to make the connection
but also a large majority of this
community is uh is Brazilian again I
cannot tell you why maybe it's because
they're closely knit I spoke to
different people in different states
that have spoken to him in the past that
had bad bad vibes even before he started
his rescue so there's a lot of things
that I'm looking into that are all right
it's all suspect if you look at any
immigrant situation and you're going to
get communities you've got you know
Brighton Beach in New York because it's
almost 100 Russian I mean you know
you've got
um just different Pockets everywhere and
it would be natural that that George
Anthony devolder Santos which is
what we believe is legal name is is is
uh would come up through a Brazilian
Community because it's where he came
from I mean so all of his early hustles
are going to be with
people that he came up with I mean it's
just makes perfect sense
yeah I mean like the people that I've
spoken to like he was he was getting in
contact with people in Connecticut in
York and like you know he claims this
this charity and I I I've also done the
digging I looked into IRS records I've
looked into Delaware business records
New Jersey business records New York
business records
for anyone who's curious about this
there is no actual charity that is
registered or was ever registered under
the name of friends of pets United
so and just to give everyone a quick and
I'm gonna dig into this more on the you
know what was that but basically the way
that the scan works
is George Santos sees people online
saying
there's a dog at a kill shelter and then
people online say I pledge five ten
twenty dollars fifty dollars whatever
George Santos sees that and then he says
that's a way to make money so that he
either makes a GoFundMe or then
redirects people to his Paypal account
and says I'm going to I the all these
people pledged money so now it's like
basically like when people do like a
run-a-thon kind of thing and they go
around and say oh will you pledge five
dollars per mile I run it's that type of
premise then you come back later and you
collect and say you pledged five dollars
per mile I ran five miles that's 25
bucks and for this
what happened was he saw those started
gofundme's or went into these groups and
said here's a PayPal here's a GoFundMe
donate the money you pledged to this
campaign and then basically he was
pawning off these animals to another
rescue and actually wasn't doing
anything with him so it's really [__]
up but that's just like that's like a
TLD it is George Santos that we're
talking about here yeah but back to the
main point uh Texas Paul because I think
um again the
the the Kevin McCarthy and I'm trying to
find Gabe can you see if you can find a
clip of Kevin McCarthy saying this or
did he say it not in front of a
microphone he just said it in front of
reporters and Reporting it
um take my hat off real quick to Brendan
Lewis in the chat by the way he'll know
why
sorry didn't mean to go no uh well I was
gonna say that um uh this George Santos
stories dropping that he's going to be
under investigate investigation in the
uh House Republicans non-ethics
committee
um if we can call it that I will
um but uh that this is probably to suck
up the news cycle and the reason why is
because all day today on on any kind of
media anywhere most commentators and
most of the coverage is going to be what
is Joe Biden gonna say and the
accomplishments that he accomplished
over the last two years he's gonna talk
about this this this this this this and
this and Kevin McCarthy does not want
the news cycle to be that Joe Biden is
um the highlight and his more more than
anything his accomplishments are the
highlight of
um this news cycle so I think he's
definitely trying to uh I think I think
he's definitely trying
to um to suck up the news cycle here
what do you think Texas ball you think
that's
fair to say oh absolutely absolutely
we've got a uh president that's doing an
incredible job I mean historic job
creation and we're not just talking
about it used to be the the knock on it
was well this is just jobs that went
away during covet no those have all been
we've got those back last year these are
new jobs and Wall Street cannot get its
head wrapped around how well this is
working this are you guys familiar with
the soft Landing
uh approach for the economy the the soft
landing approach but they took a look at
what happened they were you know the
people at the White House are [__]
amazing these guys are a Brain Trust
like you wouldn't believe they're
incredible they are incredibly smart so
what they did is that okay when's the
last time we had something similar to
covet happened and they went back to the
oil embargo during the 70s and they said
okay coming out of that
what happened to the economy let's look
at really what happened and they
prepared for that and they created
a a game plan that they call the soft
Landing because you look at Republicans
you look at Ronald Reagan we had 20
percent interest rates folks
20 interest rates you know Joe Biden had
and the FED have gone from Raising
interest rate hikes to slow things down
at percentage points down to basis
points if you know what that means
they've just gone to tweaking it at 1
100th of a percent rather than a quarter
point or a half point you know you know
25 basis points 50 bases but they're you
know five or six basis points to because
they've got such a fine-tuned control of
our economy and because they do
we're creating massive numbers of jobs
and because of the bills that they
passed you know the chip act you know
things that are really helping the
American people we created over 500 000
jobs last month when that when Wall
Street expected a hundred and eighty
eight thousand
you know folks I mean it's just it
I tell you I could rant all day
and and you've got a president that's
going to have a state of the union that
is a Victory lap
I mean you look at the bridges that
they're finally repairing he's going to
sit there and give you a list of bridges
and one of the best moments I think is
going to come tonight is when he
mentions that he went with Mitch
McConnell to fix a bridge in Kentucky
that has been promised to be fixed for
like 15 years and they kept saying oh
we'll get the money with the money get
the money get the money and they never
got the money guess who got him the
money and guess who went with Mitch
McConnell to show them that he got them
the money he didn't let Mitch McConnell
take credit for that all on his own and
Joe Biden's definitely going to dig that
knife in tonight
well he might also he might also include
the um
uh the Cincinnati Bridge which I'm
blanking um the um the the folks that
the Brent uh Spence Bridge which is the
one that Donald Trump
promised
that he Oh you mean you mean promises 40
promise is broken
um
and if you don't know folks what what
game's talking about why it's so
important the Brin Smith's Bridge 40 of
our nation's GDP
the manufacturing out of our nation
crosses that bridge that one Bridge
and also just for context Trump made
that promise back in 2016 when he was
running for president and he never did
[__] during his presidency wow he had
infrastructure week every week he had
one yeah
he act like he could drive him and [__]
all kinds of all kinds of [__] all
kinds of fake ass [__] that would make a
person think that he was doing something
he just actually didn't here's another
do nothing and again uh this is the
video of him trying to change the news
cycle folks I know you're like well why
are you showing it because I'm trying to
tell you what he's trying to do so you
can go out and and work against it point
out the people that he's trying to
change the new cycle of what how great a
job Joe Biden is doing and the Victory
lap he's gonna take tonight boom boom
boom boom boom that's the narrative
that's that's we have to fight against
this bull this [__] and this is what
Kevin McCarthy's doing here we all know
that um and George Santos is a scumbag
we all know though he's a liar we all
know that he probably should never been
to Congress in the first place but he is
and they have to deal with him we should
let them deal with him but they don't
get to steal away the news cycle of the
narrative and the messaging that we can
actually make sure that is the narrative
and messaging in this country we don't
have to let him steal it away but here
here is him attempting that
ethics is moving through and if ethics
finds something we'll take action
to be on committees
um that's that's not what yeah that's
that's different that's different he
said
he was leaving the Committees even
Marjorie Taylor green did a little PR
circuit for him to be like oh well he
thought it was best that he step away so
now McCarthy is trying to act so more
[__] lies more [__] lies it's
either lies in the beginning or lies now
and again he's trying to change the news
cycle folks he's trying to change the
news cycle standpoint of the questions
I mean he decided to step down from the
Committees
he and I had a conversation we decided
it's best at this moment I think that
was the right decision that's not what
you just said
before we move forward so ethics is
actually investigating right now yes
yes what a piece of garbage uh Texas
fall and so what do you make of the clip
now that you've seen it
I think it's just a load of [__] to be
honest with you he kept him around so he
could get his speaker votes and then now
he's going to throw him kick him to the
curb because he should have never been
in damn office in the first place you've
got an entire District what is New
York's third that he represents that are
that are without representation in the
United States Congress because nobody's
going to work with that son of a [__]
nobody he is going to get nothing done
the New York third has zero
representation because of the Republican
Party
period
um sorry about the volume on the clip I
I don't always have control we get what
we get and it just that's that was it
was just low volume and it was mono it
wasn't in Stereo so it was going to be
really low so sometimes you know we just
it's it's live
do it live do it live so I'm sorry if
you can't hear that part and our mics
are louder than the clip the clip is
just really low I had it all the way the
[__] up
um back to this real America thing and
this is going around again again more
distraction this morning
um from the America first real American
Nazi party Jesus I keep having that
that's too many
should it be real America First yes real
America First Nazi party that's better I
just call them the balloonatics the
balloonatics
I didn't think about that they did freak
out over the balloon oh my God and we're
long passable it doesn't it feel like
the balloon was three weeks ago after
the devil costume freak out yesterday
they I can't believe we're still talking
about that stupid balloon I can't
believe we're still talking about that
stupid blue wow but they are in full
freak out mode because you know they
threw all their eggs in that basket and
it blew up in their face literally so
now they've got to come back and and try
to rewrite history and and say you know
oh well we should have shot it down
before we before it crossed our
territory we should have shot it down
and then and God bless the dod on this
one God because normally they're just
we're out of this yeah but they're not
this time every time a talking point
comes out from the right the dod steps
up and says no we shouldn't have shot it
down before it hit our airspace because
uh we wanted to track this balloon we
wanted the exerciser Jam in this balloon
we this is a real world exercise that
was without Danger
we wanted this to happen and the
Wright's like well we can't say anything
bad about the dod what do we say oh well
Biden's weak you know I mean this
well I think I think what we're gonna
find out
um you know as it goes along probably in
the next 18 months uh in the lead up to
the 2024 election is that Biden actually
wanted to shoot this thing down
immediately like that was his Instinct
was to shoot it down in dod's like no
let's do is all that we can and and get
the most out of this situation that we
possibly can get and his level head led
him to I don't know listen to the people
who know what the [__] they're talking
about you were exactly right about that
they sat down on on last Wednesday they
sat down Joe Biden said shoot the [__]
down get rid of it I don't want this on
my plate I got other things coming up
and they said no
please don't please please let us have
this we'll take care of it and Joe Biden
just took the hit he didn't go on
Twitter he didn't say stupid [__] he
didn't talk with his hands you know I
mean he just let the pros do their job
took all the [__] from the right Wingers
about how this is just a disaster this
that and the other turns out the [__]
experts knew what they were doing you
know I mean right well they they do they
do in general
um know what they're doing we give them
enough [__] money they better know
what the [__] they're doing it it's my
take on it but the thing that it created
was this um and we showed the picture of
actually I think I showed it on my
patreon video over the weekend that I
did of it because I knew it would get
out of the news cycle quick I Knew by
Monday there would be someone dancing
around in the devil costume and they'd
be terrified of demonic symbolism or
some [__] just wait till next weekend
Monday is going to be all month let me
tell you I already know we can do our
thumbnail Monday right after right after
the halftime show Gabe because
Rihanna's performance oh oh my God okay
where that is exactly I guarantee he my
first words on Monday as the intro winds
down is going to be about their freak
out of the halftime show I can only
they're predictably unpredictable so
that's what's going to happen
um but here here is that what they're
doing on the real America this is why it
was trending earlier Congressman Troy
nutsack I believe is his name here I may
be saying it wrong I don't know who is
this guy he's from he's from Texas Texas
Paul the 22nd District in Texas he's a
member of The free dumb caucus of course
and technically you had it correct
that's his nehls that is pronounced
nutsack so yeah good good okay just
making sure I had it right you know I
can't read that well I'm a bumpkin so I
can't read that well and uh you know I'm
dyslexic a little bit so I just want to
make sure I get these uh pronunciations
pronounced pronunciations correct
um here's what uh Congressman nutsack
says he says real America won't believe
a word Joe Biden says tonight now what
he's saying again I said it in the first
30 minutes they mean White America it
when they say real America this is a new
branding of America First like Jim
Jordan used to post this [__] a lot over
the last couple years but they they've
started to catch on that they need to
Rebrand the America first because we
really drug it in the [__] dirt to
them I mean it didn't work for the 2022
midterm it really [__] them over they
they there was no Red Wave on the back
of this America First and with Kanye
West and Nick Fuentes going on right
wing after right wing show under the
America First Nick Fuentes Banner going
we love Hitler they were like ooh that's
not gonna work so they're Switching
gears to real America I wanted to get
away with it I want to know what fake
America is though well you know if real
America is like what are we in fake
America right now like is this
information yeah can I can I go on like
a 30 second rant about this you can
absolutely go ahead okay here's the
here's the real [__] problem here
folks it really is a problem and it's
one that Tony Gabe
myself this is what we're [__]
fighting here okay because what what
Congressman nutsack says
is is real it is really real you have
40 50 of our population
that does not believe factual data that
you put in front of them
because they have alternative news
sources and folks that was their goal
Hitler did this I went on a rant and and
did a 20-minute video that's never going
to see the light of day
about the fact that we are parroting
1930s Germany
this is what they did this is a key
function for getting fascism in your
country is to to create an entire
populace that does not believe what they
are told
the president of the United States is
going to sit up
under fact checking under the brightest
lights in our country and he's going to
tout his what he's gotten done and
Congressman nutsack is telling
every Republican out there don't believe
it
and they're not going to
they're not going to
that is a problem that is crippling to
our country we cannot function as a
democracy unless we destroy that and
that is what I do for a living that is
what Tony does for a living that is what
Gabe does for a living so I'm going to
make a selfless
gratuitous plea
we are not corporate media there's a
reason we don't give a [__] because
nobody can pull their [__]
advertising from us and [__] us we're
not because you pay for us so yes when
we ask you to buy a [__] T-shirt If
you can't every once in a while buy a
t-shirt support us make donations
Tony making Gabe make your plea I'm
telling you this is it this is really it
folks this is not us trying to dig into
your pocket
Congressman nutsack is telling you to
your face
the president of the United States is
going to tell you things
in the light of day that everyone in the
world is going to to fact check but you
cannot believe what he says You must
believe us the only antidote antidote to
that
and I love you folks that that are out
there in chat I love you folks that are
with us but it is the folks sitting here
behind these microphones screaming every
day the truth out into the void that are
that are going to change that that are
going to change that and the Democratic
party God damn us
did a miserable job fighting back you
know Tony was talking about Rush
Limbaugh he was exceptional at mind
[__] people
I hated that bastard because he was
exceptional at taking a poor white guy
and telling him your life is what you do
is exactly what you deserve
you know the raw [__] deal you're
getting is exactly what you deserve but
if you work a little bit harder you
might make it but those liberals over
there they're trying to trip you they're
trying to [__] you as bad as your life
is they're trying to make it worse and
he was a master at it he was a master at
it it takes people like Tony it takes
people like Gabe and myself and and
Midas media and everybody out there
screaming at the top of their lungs
exactly what is going on
to defeat this and it's the only way to
defeat it sorry ran over
end scene sorry no I I couldn't agree
with you more I mean I I think you know
our our voices because uh Texas Paul
want to add on to that
um we are we are three microphones we
have three of them here
um and and we are three ballots here on
the screen that is it it's all we've got
but we have the microphone that we can
speak into to give you the messaging in
the narrative to carry with you to go
out into your democracy and engage in it
and here's the thing your thousands of
microphones you're tens of thousands of
microphones you're hundreds of thousands
of ballots you're millions of ballots
and not only are you millions of balance
but your millions of microphones into
million ears out there and they have
millions of ballots and they have
millions of microphones so it starts in
one spot and and it should create this
sound that is how they do it that is how
they always sound so loud Texas Paul is
because they have all their microphones
on high all the time no matter what just
like we were just talking about with the
Super Bowl we know their microphones are
gonna be turned way the [__] up next
Monday morning about how oh my God I've
seen a thigh I've seen a thigh she had
her thigh out Rihanna what a [__] she
had her thigh out and oh yeah by the way
she may or might not be it's Rihanna you
may see a butthole I mean it's Rihanna I
told Gabe I want to bring the nipple
back I want I I think we should have I
mean I'm just saving an idea they are
all people are already making bets on uh
on what the halftime show props will be
everything from the the first song that
she's gonna sing to the color of her
outfit her hair is this is the type of
stuff that people are betting on so you
can guarantee that Republicans are
watching this like a [__] right now
oh yeah to know exactly how or what to
be prepared for when it comes out so
they can have their their their uh
sexual Anarchy tweet of the year or
whatever it might be yeah that was last
year yeah and shout out to Rihanna that
girl's gone
freaking balls like you wouldn't believe
I [__] love Rihanna you gave you know
you've been down to Venice Beach Muscle
Beach right there there's a row of
houses that are behind the beach you
know I mean that with glass railing and
they're almost all identical you know
what houses I'm talking about right I
believe you know you've seen them before
yeah yeah
so Rihanna goes and does a photo shoot
butt ass naked photo shoot
bent over with her butt facing the
camera and the camera is facing the
beach and her butt is like right there
facing Venice Beach man
forgive me so the entirety of the Beast
didn't give a crap man I mean she was
like yeah I got a great ass here you go
is the boss she is that takes a lot of
confidence I would say yeah yeah I mean
I would say yes you know it just just
like yesterday when we watched Sam Smith
I'm like it takes a lot of confidence or
Sam Smith to get into a yellow singular
jumpsuit and go out and dance right and
not give a flying [__] and what happens
is you have the Republican Party who
wants attacking for and I go if anything
people who are that confident to go out
in front of hundreds of people in person
and millions of people who are going to
watch this thing especially Republicans
who are like angrily [__]
masturbating to it that is what they do
and that is what they they get so bent
out of shape about but someone who's
willing to do that like Rihanna just
like [__] it this is who I am and I am
proud of it Sam Smith been like this who
I am and this is the music I make and
you guys the fans are are you know those
who ask for it and I'm winning Awards
here and there [__] man I don't know if
I would have the same confidence to do
that what they did you know
well let's talk about let's get our
outrage going because
um and you probably heard Texas Paul in
the first three events it gave you
probably seen this in the news who is um
going to give the rebuttal for the uh oh
no I haven't so I'm I'm ready Sarah
Huckabee no no Sarah Palin
oh man you've heard of Smokey Robinson
she's smokey eye yeah lying to America
is exhausting do you think she's gonna
wear her fake Uggs when she does it I I
don't know a lot of people have been
making fun of some of the outfits she's
been wearing as Governor I really don't
give a [__] I mean what outfit she wears
and just I care that she's actually just
making a state that is horribly in the
hole because of Republicans making it
even more horrible because she's a
[__] bigot
um but but she will lie she will yeah
straight face look right in that camera
just like I'm looking at you right now
and she will tell you the sky is pink
outside and just mean it from the bottom
of her soul she is just a flat up liar
she's gonna that is going to be her
response because there's so many damn
things that Biden has done right that
he's like you say he's going to take
that Victory lap and she's going to sit
there Point by point and she's going to
[__] lie of course she is well here I
you know Gabe you were talking about how
um people are already betting on like
what song Rihanna's gonna open with and
what some of the props are going to be
you know
it would be better if America was
betting on how many times Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was going to say the word woke
because my guess is my guess is that
will be a continuing theme uh when she's
speaking that is woke this and woke that
mother workers this and well not only
that but also saying you can't say Latin
X right which is like wherever you are
in terms of your belief on whether you
say latinx you say Latin or say Latino
Latino you know it is this is the thing
that she does is this the thing that she
does she her first day in she was like
you can't oh yeah yeah yeah now I
remember so it's like a whole thing
you're gonna tell you can't say a word
is that what you what what are you
saying are you saying you can't say a
word is that what she was saying that is
what she was saying and I just and I not
to uh not to misquote but I will let me
just look it up really quick I was
trying to out to Santa Santa this is
what she was trying
any State Communications you cannot use
the word latinx right and which is just
[__] ridiculous I mean just is this
is this an offensive word I I really
honestly I don't know I don't know I
mean here I I what I will say is within
within the Latino Community there are
people that are like oh I prefer this I
prefer that again it's total preference
right and people come from different
Generations so this is like the pronoun
kind of issue yeah I mean that's what it
is latinx is the is the gender neutral
form is one of there's lit there's Latin
which is another one and there's latinx
latinx is the one that seems to be kind
of like your one way or the other you
know I don't really care personally it's
like that's what you want to be called
us you want to be called and I have no
problem with that I'll probably default
to Latino because that's what I grew up
with
um but a lot of people this is a lot of
simple things I was talking about
earlier on one side versus the other but
it's dumb it's to band it all together
is is dumb even if you don't like it
just [__] it there's no reason to ban
something well I mean I I'm you know and
a lot of people will disagree with me on
this especially from our side but I
actually I actually think words are just
words not the context in which those
words are used like earlier
um someone you know I think in the
comments called me a bumpkin as if I was
gonna like turn to the right and I'm
some kind of country like it Bumpkin
doesn't really bother me that much I I
don't think the words that affect and
there's really not a lot of words that
offend me personally like me personally
like there's not a lot that you're gonna
say that I'm gonna hear that's gonna
offend me I just I just don't give a
[__] about words that much now I'm very
very
um cognitive that words I say may offend
someone else sometimes I say it just to
offend I mean there there is that
opportunity that you have when you are
speaking or using language
um so I think the purpose if she's
Banning the word
um what is it
um is to offend by Banning it right yeah
it's to offend people by Banning it and
it's to tell [__] useless people with
no power that only live for to to for
that dream that they've been told that
they're better than us to believe that
she she somehow made us angry she
somehow owned us she told us we couldn't
have a word and oh so oh she's badass
you know I mean it's [__] ridiculous
is what it is
well I mean she is ridiculous and we're
gonna see that on display tonight like
again we should be taking bets in this
country on how many times she will say
the word woke I wonder I just wonder how
many how many uh references to the
balloon she'll make I want to know I
want to know if she talks about uh
Candy's genitalia I really I'm I was not
satisfied with the genitalia candy talk
there was just not enough of it I think
she's gonna bring up drag because she's
also I if I remember correctly she's
trying to ban ban drag events in well I
mean she's trying to take away the civil
rights from away from from the lgbtq
community
they're going to talk about
indoctrination right the the woke
indoctrination they're going to talk
about drag and how it's uh it's a a sin
in how it is totally uh degrading our
our social
um
uh morality you know I think they're
gonna talk about all this stuff they're
gonna talk about Joe Biden the economy
they're getting inflation they probably
won't talk about jobs because that was a
big one-two punch for them
but it's gonna be all these dumb issues
these trivial things that do not
actually impact your life but they're
going to make it into a big deal right
they're gonna say the candy and the drag
shows and the the pronouns I mean [__]
it if they want to ban
I say ban pronouns band pronouns and see
how easy it is to have a conversation
[__] it go for it I dare you
yeah we ride or die Democrats are having
a drinking game every time the word woke
gets said you take a shot but we're
trying to figure out where to cap it so
nobody dies you know I mean right right
well you know and this is uh a clip that
I said I'd show in the first 30 minutes
and it's appropriate to show it here
with Sarah Huckabee Sanders because I'm
not saying these folks that are in this
clip are from Arkansas but I'm saying
these folks existed and still exist in
Arkansas but I uh Kenny posted this clip
and he said this is how your
grandparents thought about mine
um obviously Guinea is a black man
um and these are white people in this
clip now I said this is what sheet
eaters mean when they say make America
great again and in my first 30 minutes
the the and the idea that I was trying
to propose is that this real America is
a branding of America first which is a
rebranding of make America great again
and here in this clip is what they mean
about it and this is probably going to
be the thrust of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
speech tonight take a listen we will not
be coerced into hiring any colored
person regardless of his qualifications
as a matter of the arrests or as a
matter of experience when the Negro can
prove
to the white man
that he can live like the white man
then we will accept them the only thing
that scares me is the neighborhood all
getting bad and if we ever wanted to
sell naturally your house depreciation
is the color get in if they move in the
next step we have to accept his inner
marriage we can be sociable with them in
work we can get along with them and joke
with them sure but when we leave
our job and close the door and we're on
our way home we want them to go in their
Direction and we can go in
they we want them to go in their
Direction and we can go in ours Texas
Paul there is no better attitude towards
race than when I grew up in that
sentiment it's like yeah sure whatever
you know they're here there's nothing we
can do about it we wish we could but
since we can't we'll be cordial to them
in public that way no one can take cell
phone videos of us and post it online to
know where a race is but when we leave
work I want them to go their Direction
across their end of the tracks and I
want to stay on my end of the tracks and
that is exactly what make America make
America great again means that is
exactly what America First means that
exactly what these [__] scumbag
racist like like the congressman nutsack
from Tennessee's or Texas 22 Texas Texas
22 Congressman nutsack means when he
says real America will not believe
anything that Joe Biden says and the
reason why is because they're [__]
mind [__] they're delusional they
believe leave things that are absolutely
not true why wouldn't they why would
they believe the truth why when you it's
so easy to believe the lies that back up
your bias especially the bias that is in
this video
you're asking me I [__] tell you I'll
freaking tell you let me tell you about
these Bumpkin sons of [__] that live
right next to me man these [__]
trailer trash [__] hey I tell
you what easy I resemble that no no let
me tell you something man I don't know
[__] I don't mind somebody living in a
goddamn trailer that ain't my problem
you know what a trailer trash
[__] is let me tell you these
sons of [__] around here these meth
smoking no teeth haven't sons of [__]
just want to sit there and and pretend
they're better than somebody else
because they they could do [__] like
this they can say [__] like this amongst
each other then blacks just got to be
themselves and off to themselves and
said [__] you man how about you move the
[__] away from me you poor bastard huh
how about you move the [__] away from me
you [__] cheap ass stealing piece of
[__] you know my neighbor had a goddamn
feed trough stolen
[__] meth head was using it for a
goddamn swimming pool I [__] you not I
[__]
we use the water drop when I was a kid
as a swimming pool what the hell did you
steal it did you steal it no I mean no I
don't think but no please
will sit here and they will [__] talk
about black people they will talk about
Hispanic people being thieves and this
that and the other the same welfare
using
[__] stealing thieving Matthews and
white [__] will sit here and
talk about black people and these
[__] platitudes that are [__]
that are just [__] [__] we've
talked about you know if you
let me ask you what we talked about this
is go ahead is life's not better with me
and me and [__] Gabe on the same page
I mean my brother from another mother is
he his life not better his life not
[__] better okay quit being a [__]
coward and get over your [__]
[__] about you got to be told that
you're better than somebody else because
it's the only goddamn thing in your life
that you have that's decent and that's
your [__] fault you know that is your
[__] fault you don't ask anything of
these [__] people in Texas you don't
ask them to do a decent job you don't
ask them for basic health care you don't
ask them for a goddamn thing you sit
there and suck that Republican dick all
goddamn day and then the only thing
you've got left in your life is being
[__] told that you're better than a
black man or a Hispanic man or anything
like that how about you build your own
[__] life like I did God damn the
chat is lighting up Nate love when Texas
fall uh gets we pull up the cussing Pond
here on the Tony Michaels podcast and he
goes he goes to town uh we talked about
this before Texas ball where um when
white people grow up in white
communities
with no people of color no people of the
bipart community right and when they
grow up see what happens is is there's
classism that happens it's not exactly
racism but it's classism and it happens
in every Community not just white
communities but what happens is it
starts to be well we don't have people
of color here in our community but we
got those people right and those people
are the ones who are like well I might
be the lowest of the low in this
community but at least I'm not black
that well they'll use another derogatory
term but that is how they feel and that
is exactly the attitude that you're
talking about is white people in white
communities especially the ones who are
the outcast of those communities the
ones that live on the other side of town
the ones that hey I'll go to work with
them but when we leave work I want those
white people to go where they go and I
want my wife people to go where they go
it happens it's classism and and it's
the closest thing to racism than an
all-white Community has and that is the
reason why racism breeds in and that is
the reason why this this make America
great again this America First this real
American Nazi [__] has spread across
our country and and planted it cells in
the minds of the people in the white
communities who aren't who aren't the
highest in the community and that is
that is the thing that we have to
uncouple and I believe that a lot of
these folks that we're talking about
they're they don't know it they have no
clue but if they would just pluck their
head out of their ass for five seconds
and realize that they're voting against
their interest because when they when
when the higher-ups when the the donor
class when the class in power of white
people and white men especially want to
tell you you have to keep those those
people of color down because if you
don't you're gonna be the same as them
you're not right now but you're gonna be
the same as them if you don't keep them
down
that way they can maintain their power
you're on mute you're on mute it don't
mute don't mute because the chat's gonna
sorry about that no what they tell them
is that you're they're gonna get free
[__] from the government and you're
gonna get nothing you're gonna have to
work hard right and pay your taxes and
they're gonna get by for free let me
tell you something we just had a winter
storm here in Texas we just had a winter
storm here in Texas a winter storm here
is it was 30 degrees just below freezing
maybe 29 at the most and we had rain
so you know what happens to water it
makes [__] ice right shut the whole
[__] State down shut the whole
[__] State down Austin was shut down
for so long grocery stores were having
to throw their [__] meat and
dumpsters and my fellow Texas were
having to [__] dunk dumpster dive
for food
all wild
half those [__] jumping in that
dumpster voted for Greg Abbott
half of them and they will vote for him
[__] again because of this goddamn
[__] narrative that no matter how
low you are at least you're better than
this person over here that I can point
at
works every [__] time on these dip
shits Works
what about ISM and Q Anon is a hell of a
drug you talk about what out what about
ISM and narratives and disgusting
narratives this uh is one of the most
despicable Clips so far that I have seen
of people's talking about the State of
the Union
um I called him the Vogue time buffoon
he might be the bow tie Bandit formally
because he doesn't wear bow ties yeah
not anymore not after a crossfire
getting humiliated by Jon Stewart right
he doesn't he doesn't put on the bow tie
because he doesn't want to look too much
like a Rube he just sort of want to
looks like a Rube but here he seems to
me is inciting stochastic terrorism
let's take a look the administration is
so committed to democracy that they're
building a huge wall around the capital
what was formerly called the people's
house is now just their house and anyone
who's not from there can get away and
stop asking about what goes on inside
you're seeing pictures on your screen
right now you're no longer allowed in
your own house because January 6th
okay so they're putting up a fence
around the capitol because the president
the vice president the Supreme Court
Justices the entire cabinet besides one
member of the cabinet is going to be in
that building and because of the former
president inciting violence and trying
to I don't know overthrow our government
tear up our Constitution and attempted a
Cheeto dust kangaroo cool they're just
being I don't know how the word that you
put it is cautious and again if you look
at this this is a temporary fence he's
acting as if they're going to build this
permanently to where no one will ever go
in the capital but watch what he says at
the very end this this [__] scumbag
ooh it can make you hostile if you think
about it it's behind those walls that
Biden's going to read the state of the
union tomorrow and you need to stay far
far away
because it's not your country anymore a
small group of people who hate you are
running it we've got a pack
there it is
it would be it would be a bad thing if
you went and you tore down that fence it
would be a horrible thing because what
does Tucker Carlson give a [__] what and
this is um this clip was posted on
Twitter at decoding Fox News you should
go follow her she posts she watches
Tucker Carlson so you don't have to give
her a little uh promotion there because
um I I I commend her for the service
that she does by watching Tucker so we
don't have to
um but here's the thing is that Tucker
Carl's in here what are you saying is
hey I'm pointing out that they don't
want you in the building so go be in the
building if you can now it probably
won't work and the reason why it
probably won't work is because there's
hundreds of people already sentenced
hundreds over a thousand people that
have been charged and going to be uh
charged uh with uh the Insurrection on
January 6. and uh but Tucker Carlson
doesn't give a [__] he doesn't care if a
bunch of his supporters go he would love
for a bunch of his supporters to go and
be turned away at the fence or someone
to be too arrested at the fence because
oh I can't get in my building look this
is standard procedure with any [__]
president I don't care who you are what
party you're in when you were elected
since since John F Kennedy got his
[__] brains blown out in Dallas they
have made it I don't know kind of a
thing with the president of the United
States to protect it to him or her
eventually hurt which should be more
women actually all women probably
um to protect them at all costs and the
cost may be that for I don't know a
couple hours you can't walk into the
Capitol building and just willy-nilly
and that and that not be a thing listen
to me when I tell you this Tucker
Carlson is trying to get convince these
people just like he convinced the Pepe
that Nancy Pelosi is a demon and she
needs to be stopped and he went and
tried to kill Paul's Pelosi and and
hoping Nancy Pelosi was there so he
could murder her with the hammer it's
the same thing that he's trying to do to
convince them that they're building a
permanent fence even though it obviously
is not a permanent fence and that fence
will come down that barrier will come
down after this speech Texas ball you
look like you want to say something
no I was actually just sitting here
thinking about what Gabe was thinking
about this to be honest with you oh yeah
yeah what I was going to say is um I
forget to I forget the movie I think
it's Olympus Has Fallen right that's the
one with uh Gerard Butler and I think
Aaron Eckhart anyway the premise is
right that if you're going to eliminate
you know certain people uh because
if people don't know this right let's
look at the State of the Union
you have every single person of power
and the full cabinet the president the
the next in line basically if you
eliminate certain people then you just
run down the ladder of who would be in
charge right and it made me think of
this movie Olympus Has Fallen this like
little uh action movie
but it's the same premise and we've seen
in the plot points in other movies as
well which like you go in you take out
certain cabinet members you take out
certain you know the president of Vice
President then you start running down
the list of who you want to be in charge
right if you want to be the president
the interim president
um but this type of idea that that
Tucker Carlson wants to say oh well
they're they're attacking you they're
coming after you you're the Enemy of the
State and it's like well yeah no [__]
[__] because all of these Maga idiots
decided to storm the capital as Andrew
Clyde says it was a normal tourist visit
when it really wasn't well the guys the
guys scared against the wall trying to
put a desk up against the door so that
they don't get bombarded in but Tucker
Carlson wants to push this idea that
it's the government it's Joe Biden it's
the Democrats it's the left they're
coming to get you they're gonna get your
guns they're going to take your M M's
all this [__] whatever they're gonna
change these Dentures they're gonna
force you to use pronouns they're gonna
make you woke they're gonna come in and
steal everything that makes you American
away from you and that's not at all the
case and the reason you know it's
it's like when you go to
um
to a business like one time I was in
Iceland okay and I went to the bathroom
at this stop that when we were going
when we were driving around and there
was a sign in the bathroom that said do
not do this and it was literally an
illustration of a person trying to [__]
why sit by standing on the toilet and
squatting okay
like a double decker
uh no no no like you literally stand on
the toilet seat and you [__] from above
okay
so instead of sitting yourself like an
old person you hover okay
most of the world there's no such thing
as a toilet there's a hole in the ground
there's a guy with a hose and they don't
want people to emulate that and stand on
the hole in the ground right but there's
a reason yeah but the reason that you
see a lot of when you go into a place
and like please don't do this it means
that somebody did that and they had [__]
now we gotta make a rule because
somebody did this thing and we have to
make sure that nobody else thinks they
can do this thing for whatever reason so
wherever you go when you see a rule or
policy in place that says do not do this
do not touch do not play do not whatever
it's because somebody most likely did
something previously and this right now
by putting up a fence and protecting
people who are literally the people in
power of this country and Tucker Carlson
complaining and whining and bitching and
moaning about it and trying to say it's
the left pushing away the right and
saying that you're the enemy it's
it's because a certain group did it the
reason we have a rule or we have a
policy around it probably from now until
the end of time is because Republicans
were the ones who decided to have a
tantrum and Storm Into the capital and
kill people and smear their [__] on the
walls so it's like yeah you lost all
privileges of being able to just let in
you don't have to be like yeah and if
and if you think about what he's saying
there he's keeping them separated from
the goodness that is happening under Joe
Biden he's keeping them separated those
jobs numbers aren't Democratic jobs
right those are everybody's jobs right
he is setting them up so that they feel
separate from all the good things that
are going to be talked about tonight and
that they are the victim and violated
and the reason that their poor life is
so miserable is because all the people
in that building which did all that
great [__] for them they don't feel feel
like they did it for them they feel like
they're being victimized by them right
that is his whole speech uh the the chat
I I'm I'm pulling this clip up because I
want to show it and I had a good
transition but I'm thinking of another
one here but the chant is like they can
tell this is [__] Lauren bobert they
can tell it just oh yeah you know you
can't see your face all she can see is
hair a hand and she's like right I was
thinking I was thinking when did Ozzy
get glasses right so
fight them about to fight the head off a
bat right here right well she damn near
does that in this clip um so my
transition I'll give you both
transitions to see which one you like
the best you know I have the best
transitions here from from segment to
segment or clip the clip but I was gonna
go with
um speaking of a domestic terrorist
wanting to get a past defense line
um to overthrow our government you know
referring to Tucker Carlson I was gonna
shoot to Bobo but you mentioned uh
standing on a toilet seat squatting and
[__] there is no better physical
representation of that sign don't do
this then why did we elect Lauren bobert
so I don't know maybe that's a good
transition but this clip here is if
Tucker Carlson is wondering why we are
we're like hey Tech or you're inciting
violence you're trying you're trying to
get the president United States killed
here is why we're saying that Tucker
because it seems coordinated here's
Lauren bobert what seems to be in a
church by the way
um if if you're listening out there to
spot white Christian nationalism here
you go God said that he was the provider
I know that Jesus said that he that we
would be blessed but I just don't know
about this month
and Jesus is right there at the table
with you Sam
what kind of conversation is this
is that supposed to be funny I don't
know I didn't I didn't see the joke but
you know I'm an atheist so you know I
think all Christianity is kind of funny
I don't know I mean like I'm talking
about all conservative punch lines are
like just like a flat line it's again
it's the sign where you're standing over
the seat taking a [__] and you're like
don't do this dummy don't make jokes you
suck at it but let's let's continue
why are you talking like this and why
are you sad
Jesus don't you know we're out of money
covet's hit they shut everything down
Joe Biden's president
um you know it's kind of funny because I
remember when covet hit and I remember
when everything shut down and Texas Paul
it seems like there was another
president in charge at that point it
really feels like to me that there was a
guy during the pandemic in 2020 who
really [__] up the entire economy
because he wouldn't listen and he
wouldn't do what he was supposed to do
for the American people he only cared
about his reelection and what how and
and dragging Anthony fauci to make it
all be blamed on him instead of the
president United States the leader of
our country it feels like there was a
different person in church am I wrong or
was it Jill Biden was Joe Biden the
president in 2020 I I mean Lauren Bobo
seems to think he's not the president
now but he was the president in 2020. am
I Mike catching I I don't know I I just
don't smell what she's stepping in here
yeah she's no it's [__] I mean
12 20 21 and yeah and it goes back to
what Gabe and I were talking about
earlier she's called off a group of
people that need to hear a message that
they weren't wrong that they weren't
[__] stupid that they weren't [__]
idiots for voting for Lauren bobert and
and and she's given them what they need
she's giving them what they need
this is her proof to show them that it
doesn't have to be reality for them it
doesn't have to be real
because they've got them to the point
that they don't believe you lay real
data I mean just the [__]
spreadsheets man I mean no spin no
nothing just here's the data they won't
believe it they will not well let me
finish the clip because um it gets to
the part of of killing the president
pretty quickly here let's watch we don't
know what to do Lord
oh they she said the buds were Joe Biden
[Music]
all right we pray for our presidents uh
you know it says
let his days be few and another take his
office
that's why I filed articles of
impeachment for Joe Biden
unfortunately he does have a really
great insurance policy named Kamala
Harris
so she gets it to some point just just
so everyone knows she didn't file uh she
didn't file for impeachment she filed
for impeachment okay I know people
remember that well wait that is in the
Constitution
filed articles of impeachment and there
just search Google a literally an email
and she was like let's Emich Joe Biden
that's how dumb she is guys the person
who wants to impeach the sitting
president who did very good things
passing very good acts that actually
helped boost the economy and and invest
the infrastructure and those bridges and
repair certain uh aspects of our country
that's the person the person who barely
that we know of Pastor GED to run for
Congress and barely won her re-election
campaign in Colorado is the person who
wants to impeach the president okay
that's well
we're working with is that the the quote
from the Bible that she says is
something about pray for him to leave
his office or some [__] in the Bible
that is not how it goes it actually is
to um leave his wife a widower so it the
quote in the Bible apparently in Psalms
is because I don't know the Bible that
well you have to forgive me an atheist
some atheists read the Bible I do not
um well I haven't in a long time you
know I just grow they grew up Catholic
and they forced you to read the Bible
and [__] and you know they forced you it
was like indoctrination and [__] I don't
know I'm just just saying but but that
part of the Bible apparently the the
verse is that to make that person a
widower and it's referring to killing
that person
um which is the Bible verse that she's
using uh to talk about Joe Biden but I I
do find it funny how
um she wants to use Clauses in the
Constitution like impeachment
um but maybe I don't know maybe I'm just
I'm just snowballing here maybe if we go
with this whole impeachment thing and
let them do like an impeachment kangaroo
court and they have like a committee and
they pass impeachment
um on the floor of the house maybe the
Senate will just take up their meachment
um and Joe Biden can be meeched
um and you know it seems delusional
enough
but if you haven't been following Lauren
bobert what what what you're missing is
that every Sunday she is preaching now
that's what she's doing that's why this
clip is from her in church every Sunday
she's preaching in church and let me
tell you something just as plainly and
bluntly as I can say it if your church
has Lauren bobert preaching in it you
are not in a house of God you are in a
house of [__]
and you are preaching [__] falsehoods
and you are going to [__] hell
if you believe your own beliefs you are
going to [__] hell if you are in a
church that Lauren bobert is preaching
to you in
I'm going to take it as that's your vote
for my second transition of the uh
hovering on standing on the toilet seat
hovering to take a [__]
um I actually would compare Lauren
bowbert more to an actual double decker
I don't know if anyone knows what a
double decker is but it's where you
actually pull the tank lid off and you
[__] in the tank and that's kind of what
has happened in our Congress with Lauren
bobert someone took a double decker [__]
in our Congress and the brown water that
keeps going into the toilet and you're
not understanding what that smell is
it's Lauren bobert so um I'm I'm taking
your vote Texas balls for the second
transition there's a couple other things
trending here
um before we go
um Jerome Powell is trending I'm not
sure why I don't know if there's a
special announcement then today or
something
um let's see what else do we there was
something else in it uh Health ethics
Ethics Committee which uh Health house
non-ethics committee should be training
I can't say a health
twister for you half ethics yeah have
that it must be mind Bumpkin in me it
must be the Bumpkin in me that is um is
making me uh not um say it out loud we
only have a few minutes left Texas Paul
give us a Shameless plug
um this is your second week back from
your vacation so we're glad to have you
back on Tuesdays as always Texas Paul
and taco Tuesday so give us a Shameless
plug now before we round it out here
every Sunday morning from now on uh and
and barring any extra extraneous
circumstances go to my link tree it's
link.tr slash Texas Paul and uh head to
my YouTube page I will be we will be
doing Sunday morning Sunday coffee with
Texas Paul at least weekly in the
morning every Sunday from from now on I
had taken a little time off trying to
get you know vacation recharged after
the election and we are back at it my
friends
that's great so everyone go to Texas
Falls link tree and we should be able to
put it in the uh the chat there but if
not you can just go follow Texas Paul on
Twitter and I'm sure there's link trees
right there
um as well and you just click the click
the link in the Bios Gabe Sanchez uh
give us a Shameless plug I know you got
some what was that's coming up so tell
us what yeah so I got a what was that
that I'm working on that is a kind of
recap of last week just all the news
articles everything from you know Matt
Gates trying to do his PR Spain and
saying he did not ask for
um a pardon all the way to uh the the
hot air balloon uh or as as Texas Paul
calls them balloonatix and then after
that I wanted to wait until after Mike
Pence's house gets searched by the FBI
he's cooperating with FBI did Mary
different from uh Trump I wanted to wait
till after whether they find something
or not I just wanted to wait till after
so I could just wrap up this whole like
conspiracy of it's Joe Biden because you
know Margaret Taylor green says it's uh
it's an attack against Joe Biden by the
Democrats uh Tucker Carlson says it's
Joe Biden and Pence working against uh
Donald Trump like this is the Absurd
excuses and what about isms that
Republicans have to go to just to admit
to themselves that Trump actually did
something wrong they have to then say oh
it was actually both of them working
together or was this person plotting
against this it was it's all insane so
that'll probably be the follow-up on
after that
um I mean there's so much stuff I mean
I'm working on the George Santos story
as well there's so much content out
there and stories that it's hard to keep
up with where do the folks go to find
all that that you're yeah you can go to
uh twitter.com what was that show
um you can also follow me on my page I
retweet the stuff that I've been out
there as well you can go to my YouTube
which is youtube.com I am Gabe Sanchez
and I post additional clips that I don't
put on to the Midas touch Channel which
is the full episode
um so yeah check me out there
sweet should I give me a Shameless plug
even though might as well might as well
why not [__] right like the hell with
it so go go listen um what Texas Paul
said earlier you must support
Independent Media and I want to say
um I appreciate everyone who has joined
the patreon then I opened up uh out
there it is very much helped
um to support this show but I want I
want to tell you that the patreon is not
just to support this show I'm going to
be making extra content over there we're
gonna have some some patreon parties
some hangout things I'm going to open up
a uh ask me anything for 30 minutes
where if you join that tier I'll
randomly several times during the month
probably a couple times a week I'll just
say hey next 30 minutes ask me anything
when those questions come in for that 30
minutes after I post it I'm gonna answer
those questions no matter what they are
literally no matter what they are I will
give you an answer I promise so there's
that um so there's just extra content
over there um just more access to like
behind the scenes here and I'm trying to
think of some ways to do some behind the
scene things so give me some ideas so
that's what I'm asking is give me some
ideas of what behind the scenes things
that could be posted over on the patreon
that you guys want to see that you would
like to have available uh when you enter
those tiers and you are part of that
membership and part of the community the
[__] em fam over on patreon so and also
go to store.dtonymichaels.com
again I always like when people can get
something for their support and merch is
kind of an okay way to do it so go to
store.thedonymichaels.com it's always
great to get support there but again go
to thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com all the links are there to
the patreon the store uh even Gabe's
merch stores over there Texas well I
should put a link for you over there too
um I'll try to work yeah I'll try to get
a um a link over there for you today so
everybody is keep supporting
pro-democracy and uh Independent Media
what were you gonna say you were going
to say time something small yeah
you see me with all the different
customers but my wife makes these for me
and they are not the same as the Texas
Paul March as you can tell they're
they're very different and for folks
that are supporters as Shameless as I
can be here I'm going to tell you
um randomly we'll be picking supporters
that throw us some uh support if you go
to my link tree and whatnot uh they'll
con you know
but Mrs Texas Paul will contact you and
we will get you some random piece of
one-off it'll be a one-off it's not
something that anybody else is going to
get
uh piece of merch we're going to send it
to you
just for being a supporter very cool
well support keep supporting
pro-democracy
um and and Independent Media everywhere
and we couldn't do it without you the
voice you are our voice you are our
voice it's the reason why we keep
talking into the microphone whether you
like it
not everyone tomorrow is going to be a
hell of a day because we're going to
start off I know with the absolute freak
out of the thing I don't know if it's
going to be Eminem genitalia gas stoves
these balloonatics I don't know if it's
going to be Joe Biden is going to come
out in the devil costume and sing Unholy
I'm not really sure what's gonna happen
and what they're gonna freak out to but
they'll be freaking out tomorrow and we
will be breaking down why they're
freaking out and why it matters to your
democracy so same time same place
tomorrow Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon